we've got some great stuff coming up
next week on the David Pakman show first
of all I will interview Arthur Caplan we
will talk to him and ethical and ethics
expert on medical ethics we will talk to
him about the ethical and moral
questions surrounding genetic editing I
think it will prove to be a very very
interesting conversation i will also
interview Roberto Gonzales on the topic
of immigration and particularly youth
immigration and how immigration affects
families I think it will be a very
unique look although I shouldn't really
say very unique unique is by itself a
term that does not need to be modified
it will be a unique look at immigration
around the world also on Wednesday
Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show will be sitting in studio
with me co-hosting always uh exciting to
have been here people seem to like Ben
or really really hate him both of which
are good for the show we will also be uh
starting our first longer-form piece the
subject of the first piece which will
air partially on Monday and partially on
Tuesday will be about Reza aztlán can
reza aslan be trusted is he a religious
historian as he claims to be or is he
not send in questions for any of the
guests send in guest ideas we always
like to book guess that the audience
wants to see and I am very much looking
forward to what should be a great week
of shows next week the week of January
11th 2016